- Can I get a clap from Buck?
Excellent, Buck.
And we go live in three, two.
- My name is Annie Roth,
and I am a journalist
on assignment
with National Geographic.
- My name is Melissa Márquez.
I'm a shark scientist
aboard the "Ocean Explorer."
- And like Melissa said, we are
aboard the "Ocean Explorer,"
which is a huge vessel dedicated
to science and media production.
Right now, we're in mission control,
watching a remotely operated vehicle
sending down to--
what have we got?
[speaking indistinctly]
- To 231 meters.
- 231 meters,
and we're watching two submersibles
that are already down on the bottom
that are there to study six-gilled sharks,
the biggest deep-sea shark out there.
And they already have some fish down there
and a tube filled with chum.
And we're just playing the waiting game,
hoping for these sharks to show up.
We've already seen two of them.
And we're hoping
that another one shows up.
And yeah, are you excited?
- Yeah. Very excited.
- We've been up for a couple hours,
so bear with us.
And meet our awesome ROV pilots.
- I am Olaf.
- And I'm Euan Bason.
- We've also got one of our
sub pilots over here.
- I am, uh, Buck Taylor.
- Did you forget your name?
[laughter]
- It's been a long night.
- I know.
- So sharks are nocturnal, and so is
the crew of the "Ocean Explorer"
for the next couple days.
And yeah, it's taken a toll,
to be honest with you.
[laughter]
But right now, there are two subs down,
and there are three people
in each of them.
And they are hoping to see the six-gills
because they are conducting
not only a ambitious filmmaking project
to film
these sharks in their natural habitat;
they're also trying to tag them.
So their goal is to attach
two different kinds of tags
to the six-gill sharks here
to learn about their vertical migration
or distribution,
how they spend their time.
They want to know what they're up to.
They want to know how climate change
is impacting them.
They want to know
what they're eating
and just, like,
what they're doing with their time.
Who doesn't want to know?
These sharks are awesome.
Of course we want to know
what they're doing.
Yeah.
Anything else
you want to say about sharks?
- No, you've taken everything
out of my mouth.
[laughter]
- These sharks are super cool.
They can grow up to 20 feet long.
They can get as big
as great white sharks.
They haven't changed much since
they shared the planet with dinosaurs.
They have, like, really cool eyes.
They have, like,
really small dorsal fins,
like, way in the back of their body.
They're not like your typical shark.
And they're kind of the kings down here.
Their only predators are each other
and queens, hey.
- We're seeing females.
They're the queens.
- And yeah, the subs have had a lot
of luck seeing these sharks
over the past couple days.
And they've even,
like, bumped into the sub.
So yeah, there's been
some fun shark activity.
And we're hoping to see some more here.
Right now, we're just looking at, like,
a bunch of horse mackerel.
And we saw an eel earlier.
So just keep your eyes stuck to the feed,
and you might see something neat.
You know, if you like fish,
then you came to the right place.
We are on the Condor seamount,
which is a protected seamount
here in the Azores,
which is 800 miles off the coast
of Portugal.
It's an island archipelago.
And the reason we've come here is,
there are a ton of these sharks.
Fishing for these sharks here
was banned several years ago.
And this particular seamount
is protected,
so the population here is just thriving.
And it's no coincidence
that every night these subs
have been down, they've seen one.
And it's a sign of a really healthy
ecosystem overall here.
When there's a bunch of top predators,
it just speaks volumes about the health
of the entire ecosystem.
Yeah, it's fun to see.
I'm having a great time.
Definitely not tired at all.
[laughter]
- Guys down there are playing
the waiting game, that's for sure.
- Mm.
- Yeah, the people in sub have been
down there for quite some time.
But they brought some snacks, keep them
entertained and fed, so that's good.
- There's card games.
- Yeah. We've got the two subs,
"Nadir" and "Neptune."
"Neptune's" a science sub.
So we have two scientists
on board or on pilot.
And then "Nadir" is our filming sub.
We have a director,
cameraman, and a pilot.
And so you can't see "Nadir"
at the moment.
She's in the dark,
hiding out of the way.
And I've been piloting
the last few nights.
I'm out tonight.
But just to see those sharks--
we've spent a lot of time last few days
just to see those sharks cruise by,
and cruising is--it's impressive,
isn't it?
- It's amazing.
I mean, it really is like
looking at a dinosaur, essentially,
just a dinosaur of the deep.
They're absolutely--
- Shark.
- Oh!
- Yeah, here he comes.
- Coming in bottom left, bottom left.
- There she goes.
- Look at you.
- Wow.
- Slow moving but so powerful.
- They get their nose under the sub.
- Oh, oh, oh.
- So this is a 12-meter-wide sub.
- Come on, come on, come on.
Come on. Come on.
- Oh, boy.
- Go! Come on, baby. Come on.
- So the sub that the shark
is in front of is a science sub.
So there is two spears--spearguns
mounted on the top
that are armed with tags, which is how
they're trying tag these sharks.
This shark didn't get quite in range,
but look how huge it is.
The sub is, like, 12 feet across.
And so you can kind of see
by perspective how big this shark is.
- Well, that tube on the seafloor
is 1.8 meters long.
- Yeah.
So what the scientists are waiting for--
we have two green lasers
that shine out from the sub,
and they're in line
with the two spearguns.
And they're waiting for that to go
just below the dorsal--
or just below the sort of lateral line
or above the lateral line
into the sort of muscle there.
So this is tough for the guys, you know,
moving the sub around quickly.
And so they have to sit
and wait for that shark--
- Come back around.
- Come on, baby.
Come on.
- Wow.
- And so they're very patient,
these guys.
They'll just sit and wait
and get the perfect shot.
- For hours and hours.
- Hours and hours.
- We run out of snacks. We cry a little.
- And you've been in that sub.
It weighs a ton.
But when they want to move the sub,
they'll move the sub, won't they,
the sharks?
- Yeah, yeah, oh, 100%.
- They'll put their nose underneath
and just push you around.
- It's a bit funny
how easy these sharks move.
- Hold on. Come back around.
What's--from the bottom--
No, wait. Where is it?
- It's just underneath us.
- Oh, it's underneath us.
- The sharks have been doing this
every night.
They'll pick up the scent
and start circling round
and gradually hone in
and work out where the bait is.
So--
- It disappeared.
- It's underneath us.
- It's just underneath us.
- No, it's disappeared, you guys.
It sucked it up.
Do you remember how I said that you were
gonna do, like, alien abduction stuff?
You've alien abducted the shark.
So if you're just tuning in,
we just saw a--
[laughter]
We just saw a six-gill shark,
and we are watching--
- Wait, hold on a second.
- Oh, come on, baby.
- Incoming.
- Here we go.
- No, get closer.
- He's picking up that scent.
- Get closer.
- So they can't just tag the shark
anywhere.
It has to be in the perfect,
like, spot on its back.
- Oh, come on.
- Here--oh, oh.
- No, no.
Come on.
- Wow.
- If he turns to the left now--
- Turn, turn, turn.
- Turn, turn.
- She's gonna go to the vapor.
There's fish on the vapor.
Up her nose.
- Of course she is.
- Wow, the sub's
getting a real show right now.
- So the three guys in the sub,
they'll have a front view.
- He just booped the sub.
- Yeah.
- Oh, my God. Oh!
- Wow.
- That's a big shark.
- Look at that!
- Okay. Just go off, I guess.
- To give you an idea of size,
that's four meters.
- Wow. Four meters.
- Yeah.
Wow, that was such
a dramatic shot just now.
- That's about max size for them,
isn't it, Buck?
- Sorry?
- 20 feet is about max size for them.
- Wow.
- That we know of, yeah.
So on average, they're 14, 18.
- Yeah, they get a little bit
bigger than that, but yeah.
- Yeah.
- Wow. Oh, turn around.
- Here she comes again.
- Coming back.
- There she goes.
- Come on.
- It's all about that scent.
And you can see her eyeball.
- Oh, you can see her eye.
- Yeah.
- Wow.
- Those eyes are amazing.
They just roll around in their head.
- Oh, my goodness.
- Beautiful shark.
- They are.
- The tags they're trying to attach
to the shark will allow scientists to--
- There she goes.
- Oh!
- Come on, baby girl.
Come on. Yes, come on.
- If she turns...
- Turn, turn, turn.
- Oh, boy!
both: Turn, turn, turn.
- Now, so the problem is, we have to…
- She's just teasing the sub.
- Place that bait, but I think there's
a bag of fish blood in that corner.
- Yes.
- And so she's--
- Oh, yeah, that's true.
- Her nose is very, very, good.
She knows exactly where that is.
- Well, imagine being in the sub
right now.
They're really getting
the full experience.
- We've had that.
It's pretty amazing,
them getting that close and--
- Oh, she got it.
Got the bag.
[laughter]
- That's it.
We're never seeing that bag again.
[laughter]
- We'll pick it up before we go, though,
won't we, Buck?
- It's well protected.
She can't get hold of it.
- There she goes.
I don't think she's done with us yet.
- A little bit of a tease,
but we do leave some behind.
Well, they normally will pick bits
off the bar.
- There she goes.
- What a beautiful fish.
- Wow.
- Great shot, Jeremy.
- Yeah.
- Wow.
- That is stunning.
- Oh, little bit of a turn.
- Oh, she's turning.
- Oh!
- Come on.
- She can't get enough.
- Yeah.
And they've been doing this every night.
They come in.
They have a sniff, a nibble,
and then they'll pull away again
and might get spooked with all the lights
and they'll just cruise back in again.
Great work with the ROV, guys.
- We're getting so lucky
with this renowned huge shark.
Really just, you know,
so interested in the bait.
You must have really stabbed it up good.
- Yes.
- [laughs]
- She's just cruising
on the edge of the lights.
- But yeah, scientists want to--
oh, what's going on?
- Just on the starboard side.
Here she comes.
She's gonna come in from the--
- Another shark?
- No, it's the same one.
- Same one. She's just turning.
- Yeah.
- So yeah, scientists want to attach a tag
to this shark that will--
- She's coming in high.
- Coming behind the sub, yeah.
- Okay, coming left.
- Scientists want to put a camera tag
and a satellite tag on these sharks.
Allow them to see what they're doing,
where they're spending their time,
what they're eating.
All kinds of things that we have not
really been able to study
because of how inaccessible
these sharks are.
- How important are they
to the ecosystem?
- Take it away, shark expert.
- No, you've been doing a great job.
- Well, they're the apex predator
down here.
So having them in such healthy numbers
really just speaks volumes
about how healthy the ecosystem is.
- Oh, yes.
- Here she comes. Nosy.
- It's another one. There's another one.
- There's two?
- Oh, that's smaller.
- Yeah, there is.
- There's another one.
- Yeah.
- We got double shark time.
Wow.
- Wow.
- It's really shark o'clock over here.
- Yeah, we've also seen the last couple
of nights, when you get more
than one shark at the same time,
the big sharks, they're very dominant,
and the small ones
will disappear quite quickly.
And it's very obvious
when a larger shark comes into the area
'cause they just scan past them.
- The only predators the sharks have
are each other.
So if you're a smaller six-gill,
a big six-gill is,
like, kind of scary, very sus.
- Yeah.
- But yeah, they're mostly scavengers.
Is that correct?
- Yeah. Yeah, yeah.
So they are ambush predators.
They do scavenge.
They're opportunistic.
- So I would imagine that helps keep
the ecosystem pretty healthy too.
- Yeah, yeah. Definitely.
- [laughs]
- Hard to sex from this angle,
but we've been seeing mostly females,
haven't we?
- Yeah, yeah, we've pretty much seen--
- Any reason why?
- We have no idea.
I mean, one of the things about deep-sea
sharks, it is hard to study them.
And so being able to get to do so
from a sub is something
that we're very privileged
to be able to do.
- There she is.
- Coming back.
- Incoming.
- Getting to see them in situ,
or getting to see them
in their environment like this,
is a really cool, rare opportunity.
So yeah, we don't really know that much
about their population structures
and dynamics.
- There's a lot of unanswered questions
about these sharks,
which is why it's so important to have
scientists study them like this.
It's a real treat for science
to have ROVs and submarines
at their disposal.
The local scientists here
that are working with "Ocean Explorer,"
they're pretty stoked, to be honest.
Getting tags in these kind of sharks
before was less than ideal.
They would catch them at depth
and pull them up to the surface,
put tags in them.
And the experience kind of messed
with their behavior for several days.
And it was traumatic for the sharks,
so to be able to attempt to tag them
down here
and observe them down here is a really
special opportunity for scientists.
And are they gonna come back around or...
- It's around there somewhere.
- Yeah.
- Mm-hmm.
- Oh.
- And we've also got the other sub--
the filming sub's
on the left-hand side of the scene.
She sat there with all the lights on,
and she gets a much better view as well
because she can look out into the dark
and see what's going on.
- So the subs down here are not just
trying to do science.
There's a--like Buck was saying,
there's a media sub.
So that sub is gonna give people
a really unprecedented
look at these sharks.
And they've never really been
filmed like this before.
They've just spent so much time
down here over the past couple days
filming them in different locations
around the Azores.
And it's a treat for people
who tune to National Geographic Channel,
too, in the future.
If you stumbled upon us while
scrolling absentmindedly, what up?
We're watching sharks.
Lucky you, you came at the best time.
There's two sharks
circling these submarines.
And you've probably never seen
a shot like this before.
So, like, don't keep scrolling.
Just keep watching.
Unless you hate fish and sharks.
Then just please--by all means.
- You can't sit with us.
- And they're not that scary, really,
are they?
- No.
- Beautiful, not scary.
- Sharks are friends.
- Aren't they also called cow sharks,
these sharks?
- Yes.
- Yeah, see, like, cute name, cute sharks.
What's not to love?
- You're a shark expert yourself.
Why am I here?
You can take my job.
- Hardly.
I'm just what you call a shark stan.
Big fan of the sharks.
[device beeps]
- Screaming.
- Is that the shark alarm?
- Yup.
- Perfect. Code red on the shark alarm.
- Perfect.
- Melissa, how can you tell
what sex they are?
- Shark.
- Oh!
- Shark incoming.
- Look, it was a shark alarm.
- Yeah. Where is he?
- Come on, baby. On the left.
- Okay, bottom left. Thank you.
Can you go left? All right, gotcha.
- The bottom left.
- Yeah.
- So welcome to my TED Talk,
where I talk about shark claspers,
AKA shark penises.
That is how you can tell whether a shark
is a female or a male.
They basically have the two extensions
of their pelvic fins,
which are the fins beneath their body.
Yeah.
- Yeah.
- And so you have two of them
because there are two pelvic fins.
And they're shark penises. There you go.
I did literally a TED Talk...
- Penises?
- About them. Penises.
- Penis eye?
- Penis eye, maybe, yes.
- Penis eye.
- Peen eye.
[laughter]
- All right, moving on.
- We keep it classy here
at National Geographic.
- And anyway, girls don't have those,
so let's get--
- That's how we can tell
whether they're...
- Boys have two. Girls don't have any.
- Boys or girls.
Mm-mm.
- And the girls are bigger, right?
- Girls do tend to be bigger, yes.
This is why they are the queens
of the ocean down here.
- We saw one a couple of days ago,
and she was so wide, so wide.
You know, it'd be great to be able
to do an ultrasound to see
if she had pups inside.
- Yeah, she--there are
some big sharks here.
Absolutely gorgeous.
And it's really interesting
'cause the subs are about eight tons.
- Yep.
- Yep, eight tons.
And these sharks can bump 'em
and move 'em like nothing.
So that tells you
how strong they are.
- Nose underneath,
a quick flick of the tail, and--
- Yeah, pretty much.
- Yeah.
- Must be fun for those in the sub.
- Oh, incoming. Port side.
- There we go, baby.
- Yeah, just about to come to the light.
- Coming from the left-hand side.
- There she is.
- Here we go.
- Yeah. Oh, this is--
- Hey, girl, hey.
- If she turns now onto the bait,
this will be a great tagging opportunity.
- Come on.
- Turn, turn, turn.
- Come on, baby girl.
- Come on.
- She's thinking about it.
- Yes!
all: Come on.
- Girl.
- This could be--
- Get it, get it, get it.
- No! You tease.
- [laughs] She's like, "Nah, forget it."
- She's smart.
- And you have to be so careful
with those triggers
and not get trigger-happy.
And it's so frustrating 'cause you can
see the lasers coming under the shark,
but, you know, you need--
- You've got to get her
in the perfect spot.
- Right place so it's safe for the shark
and you know the tag's gonna stay on,
so...
- They only really have, like, one shot.
They can't reload.
- Two.
- Oh, well, for each tag. Yeah.
But there's no reloading down there.
They have to come back up.
- And it takes hours to come back up
and reload everything.
- Oh, went pretty good.
Hour and a half now.
- Ooh.
- No, no,
that's how long it took last time.
- [laughs]
- Trust me, I was there.
I know how long.
- If you're just tuning in, we just saw
a six-gill shark, and it was so awesome.
And we're hoping she comes back.
She's, like, the size of the sub.
And yeah, we're here in the Azores.
We are--how deep are we?
- 231 meters.
- 231 meters down,
which is hardly as deep
as these sharks can go.
They can go how deep?
- 700? Is that what you said?
- Over 1,000 feet deep.
These sharks hang out super deep.
And scientists think they come up
to the shallower waters to feed.
But there's lots of unanswered questions
about these sharks
'cause they're very mysterious;
they're very hard to study
because they spend
so much time in the deep.
And that is why we have
a submersible down here
trying to tag them
and answer these questions.
And, like, just, you know,
check out cool sharks,
'cause who doesn't like to do that?
You clearly do.
You're tuning in to this.
So hey. Welcome to the party.
- How many people are in that sub?
- Three people.
- There's three people in each sub.
Yeah.
So the science one
has two scientists and a pilot.
And the media one has a director,
cameraperson, and a pilot as well, so...
- So can you explain where the media sub
is right now?
I don't think we can see it.
- No, it's probably--the media sub's
down there.
We're creating an arena.
So we have the ROV up above,
the "Neptune," which is the science sub
with the lights on
that you can see there,
And then the media sub "Nadir"
to the port side.
Now, she's completely blacked out
so the sharks--
and they will tend to ignore her.
And so we're creating
this arena of light.
The sharks are coming in.
We've got the bait there.
So they cruise in. They get the scent.
And we place that based on experience
so that we, you know,
try and get them to line up
in front of the tagging devices
so we can get those tags in.
Now it's the waiting game.
- If you're thinking that the people
in the subs have the best jobs
in the world,
you're right, they do.
- Thanks.
But don't tell my boss that,
'cause he'll cut our pay.
- [laughs]
- But these ROV boys
are quite lucky as well
'cause they get to do the same, but...
- I was gonna say.
- They can eat popcorn.
- They can go for a cup of tea
halfway through.
- And the bathroom.
[laughter]
- Yeah, Buck, do you want to explain
how the bathroom works in the sub?
- Bathroom. Okay. We can do liquids.
But we're not very good at solids.
So just bear that in mind
when you come in.
It's not very discreet.
If you imagine three of you
in an acrylic sphere
with a internal dimension of two meters.
- Cameras everywhere.
You hold up a little towel
for a little, you know, discretion,
to be discreet there.
But we have these things
called TravelJohns, and they're unisex.
And they turn urine into--
I would say--it's meant to smell nice,
but I would say acceptable-smelling gel.
- Oh.
- Yes.
So you can then handle it
in a semi-hygienic way.
But yes.
It's funny, though.
We--you know, eight, ten hours
in the sub, people think,
"Oh, my God, what do you do?"
And I tell people to stay hydrated.
The chemical reaction
to take out the carbon dioxide
'cause you're in a sealed unit
actually dehydrates you.
And so you can come out
with a headache.
So if you just treat it as, you know,
a normal day,
you know, sat here,
drink normally,
and it's a time machine.
You jump in for a seven-hour dive,
and it goes like a flash.
- Wow.
- It really does, so...
And hopefully we're gonna get you in
next couple of days.
- Oh, I hope so.
That'll be so cool.
- [laughs]
That will be good.
- Yeah.
- Get some shark action.
- Would literally die.
- [laughs]
Right, come on, sharks.
Keep seeing shadows,
but it's just the smaller fish
casting big shadows down there.
- There's still plenty
of bait down there.
That's why the other fish
are still circling so close.
So there's good enough reason
for the sharks to come back.
- And although those fish
along the bait tube are eating our bait,
they're actually stirring it up.
So they're doing a good job to send
the fish and blood into the water column
and get it out there as a scent trail.
- And compared to the past
couple days,
like, this is not even that many fish.
There's been swarms of fish surrounding
the subs the past couple nights.
Like, so much that they could barely
see through them to find a shark.
- Yeah. Olaf, explain what it does
to your instruments,
you know, when you've got
that many fish in your--
- Well, we have a altimeter
on the bottom--
or a DVL on the bottom of that ROV,
and if fish swim underneath,
it does, like,
tend to give us a false return
on the acoustics,
so it can push the ROV off into
a different direction
[indistinct]
or give us a false return on a altitude,
which then can kick us up or down. Yes.
- I got shouted at by Buck
for coming down too quickly.
[laughter]
Come down five meters.
- That's because--
- That's not five meters!
- That's 'cause they think you're gonna
squish the sphere when we see your--
everybody thinks of an ROV
as quite a small vehicle,
but imagine a minivan
coming at you at 20 miles an hour
and you're sat on the bottom of the seabed
in this delicate little plastic sphere.
And you know that Olaf
and Euan are upstairs
with big smiles on their faces.
[laughter]
It adds to the excitement, anyway.
- ROV, stop.
- Stop, stop, stop.
[laughter]
- And the bag is full.
- So where are these sharks? Come on.
- Yeah, sharks.
Giving us a little tease.
If you missed it before,
there were two huge sharks.
We're not bluffing. They were here.
So we're just playing the waiting game
and keeping an eye out for anything else
that wants to show up.
The past couple nights,
random animals have shown up.
There was a mola mola just hanging out,
which was quite a sight to see at depth.
And yeah, I want to see
some more sharks, though,
'cause they're kind of
what's popping down here.
- Yeah. I think the most amazing scene
this week
was, I was sat in the media sub filming,
looking up, seeing the other sub
and the ROV,
which is pretty amazing anyway.
And you get this whole arena.
And as you say,
the mola mola just gliding in.
And then a six-gill underneath.
And you have to pinch yourself
because it's just completely unreal.
- That's so cool.
- Yeah, absolutely amazing.
We're in a special place here.
Really are.
- Yeah, it's no coincidence that
there's so much awesome life here.
The protections for this particular
seamount, the Condor seamount,
and the surrounding waters
are really good.
And so when you protect marine ecosystems,
this is what you get.
Tons of fish, tons of sharks.
Perfect balance.
Sometimes so many fish
that you can't see the sharks.
But that's fine 'cause that's what we want
to see when we're not filming, I guess.
- We prefer it that way.
- Yeah.
- Even if it makes filming
a little more difficult.
- Very often, we'll get to seamounts
and all you'll find is very little life
and just fishing gear
everywhere on the bottom.
And it's just--it's soul-destroying.
- And litter.
- Yeah, litter--beer bottles...
- Pick up your litter.
- Plastic and--yeah, it's--
whereas this is amazing.
Yeah. Beautiful.
- Mm-hmm.
Worth staying up late for.
- Yeah, definitely.
Yeah, those guys will be probably
getting into the chocolate stash by now.
And they've got their--they've had
their evening meal
which Kirstie and the girls
would have prepared.
But they'll be getting five into the
chocolate and playing the waiting game.
- How good is the meal
on board the subs?
- How good?
It's a meal. It's great.
- It's amazing.
- The people who go in the subs
bring plenty of snacks
'cause they're down there for a while,
and, you know, watching sharks eat chum
I guess makes you hungry.
- It's not the healthiest environment
because you just sit there
and eat food all day and you don't
actually move very much, so...
- All right.
- Just need those sharks
to pick up on the scent trail now.
- Why don't you zoom in on the seafloor
a little bit?
We can talk about the corals.
Is that possible?
- What? Corals?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, we can just zoom in on that.
- So yeah, if you see
those long thin strands
coming from the seabed,
those are whip corals.
And then the yellow ones
I believe are sea fans.
There's a purple sponge
down there somewhere.
I lost track of it, but, like,
you guys have your eyes
on the screen.
Find it.
- It's actually right by--it's right by
the chum flute there somewhere,
that purple one is.
- Oh, yeah.
- And don't worry about what you see with
the plastic drum and the plastic tube.
Everything we take down,
we bring back up again.
And very often, we'll bring trash
back up with us if we see it
and we've got space to put it
on the subs or the ROVs, so....
- Yeah.
- We generally bring back more
than we take down.
- The ROVs and the subs
have mechanical arms
that they can use to pick stuff up
and pass stuff to each other,
which is very funny to see, honestly.
- Can you give us a wave with your arm?
- I can give you a wave with the arm.
- Oh, yeah.
- Try not to scratch the camera lens.
- Without scratching the camera lens.
- Yeah.
- Maybe we should bring
the camera in a little bit.
- See, Jamie's gonna shout at me now
for suggesting that 'cause he's--
- Well, we just need to retract it
on its tray a little bit.
- Yeah.
And you know this is when the shark--
- The shark will come.
- Exactly.
- Zooming out and straightening up.
- So each of the subs have one arm each,
but the ROV has two arms.
- Do you want to--turn the head in.
[indistinct radio chatter]
Keep the camera in the light.
- That's just the subs talking there,
so...
What's that, Lee?
- Zoom out.
- Was it shark or not?
- Mm?
- Any sharky or not?
- He's asking for permission
to turn on the ROV lights.
- Oh, okay.
[indistinct radio chatter]
That's the--you can hear
in the background
the two subs talking to each other.
And then we can talk to them
in mission control.
And then we also have a tracking system
so we know where the two subs are.
We know where the ROV is and the ship
can follow all the different assets
around the seabed.
- What's that?
- What are we looking at?
- Zoom in center.
Hold on, there's, like, a--
oh, maybe it's gone.
It was, like, a very long fish.
Maybe my eyes were just
playing tricks on me.
- No, gonna wait until the arm's moved.
- So we're coming up towards the end
of our time together.
So if you stumbled upon this,
thanks for watching.
And if you appreciate sharks and fish
as much as we do,
then you're really cool;
we should hang out.
- And Euan's just gonna give us
a little wave with his arm.
Does that mean it's a goodbye wave?
- There it is.
- Hey!
- The claw.
[laughter]
- Aw.
- There you go.
- Bye-bye.